our school got a basketball team for the
first year
and i was in seventh grade and if you
were in eighth grade you automatically
were on varsity and then or something
like that and everybody else had to try
out so we tried out i wasn't good you
know but i tried out i was good in like
my neighborhood you know when people
came in and had like skill sets you know
i mean i wasn't good right and so
everybody made varsity and everybody
else who didn't make it automatically
you want to play you could and that was
jv and then the coach for jv we didn't
have one and so my friend's mom
volunteered
and she volunteered and she just was
like learning basketball with us
and then we used to have it was like it
was literally like the like like the
like the molly crew of it could have
been a cartoon it was like all those
castaways on this team
and we used to have these these these
practices and she used to have a
clipboard like the dry erase clipboard
and just be like go this way you know i
go to
our first game we played 14 games that
year we went 014
our first game
uh i was like watch we're going to play
these kids that are definitely like
these kids are all going to be from like
urban areas they're going to be like
sure enough every kid on team was six
foot
and uh we
and they like played basketball black
basketball was life for them as opposed
to us they they beat us 44 nothing
44 nothing dude and then after you'd
line up in the middle of the thing to
get hands and like then go get a snack
upstairs we used to play at the catholic
organization with the cyo yeah so it was
a cyo league so it was all the catholic
tools right so we would say thank you
but at the end of the first game it was
traumatizing dude at the end of the
first game the parents were so into it
on their side yeah right and they were
screaming and yelling and everything and
then at the buzzer
the parents
started to chant
44 zip zip 44 zip 44 and they just came
down off the stand they were screaming
it and waving [ __ ] and while we were
trying to shake hands they were getting
our face like 44 zip zip and then we had
to go up the steps together to go to
like the the like common area to have
like our capri suns and we were going up
the stairs and they were screaming it
was
bellowing in the hallways and they were
screaming at us 44 zip zip and i was
like damn man it was traumatizing damn
now we scored points in every other game
but we never got shut out again but we
went on 14 the second game 56 to three
we lost i had the three points you did
yes
and then they still did the we still
were part of the awards dinner
we were part of the awards dinner at the
end of the season
dude
here's the worst part of it i was the
team's mvp
i swear to god i accepted the award i
got up and i took the trophy in front of
everyone
at the dinner you've had to pay to be
there i had 16 points on the season
total total yeah 16 points and i was mvp
praise god is that great but did it give
you some confidence though no really
really really knock my confidence down
just game after game just 14 games of
burying my confidence in the last game
of the season we didn't realize we
something happened with the universe and
we were like landing shots we were
sinking shots and then at the buzzer we
we huddled up and our coach goes
look up and we looked up and we were
winning it was like 14 13 or something
and we went we just look at each other
like we're winning we're [ __ ] winning
we lost
but it was like that was all like that
was like our big moment like our rudy
moment like at the head look up
yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one